so would nothing but Star Wars news or
at least a title that's right the
official title for Star Wars Episode 8
hit the Internet today it was revealed
to be Star Wars the last Jedi an ominous
red Star Wars lettering what did it mean
the baddies are coming but alright the
last Jedi let's speculate about that
which is funny it's just a title I was
like ok the new title I've never gotten
so many tweaks to do a video about a
title then win the title for Star Wars
the last Jedi to hit the Internet as
well I loved it the first thought I had
ok Luke is clearly gonna have a bigger
part in this movie it is said that Luke
is going to have a bigger part in this
movie rather than you know the cameo not
even cameo the scene at the end with no
dialogue for 5 seconds he had in the
force awakens now it really seems like
him being this it might as well be
called Star Wars Luke Skywalker and I
say that thinking yeah the last Jedi
could mean a few different things I'm
going to for now we're going to talk
about those other things in the second
but for now I'm thinking Luke Skywalker
because in the force awakens only Luke
Skywalker was ever reference to be the
last Jedi in the opening Crawley's
references the last Jedi even Snoke
called him the last Jedi so there that
is so now there's what's called the last
Jedi Velvia here comes over I know that
Jedi is a singular and plural term so
the last Jedi could be hey look they're
the last Jedi he'd be talking about both
of them and it'd be an ominous red
lettering in the last Jedi there's a big
part of me that thinks it could be a
passing of the torch thing the movie
could start out Luke Skywalker is the
last Jedi then the movie ends with Rey
the last Jedi supplies Luke will die but
I do know that in the Star Wars universe
of Jedi dies it's just going to be in
the next one barcodes may be however
Luke has been hurting out in this place
that was supposedly the first Jedi
Temple is where we get the speculation
because we Star Wars fans we love that
I'm a grown-ass man wearing a Star
Wars blanket as a cape don't look up to
me too much but why did Luke go there
did he somehow find some fable of
someone who's known as the last Jedi
that you know predates him by many many
years centuries millennia whatever go in
fact people don't really know a lot
about this movie all we know for sure is
it's called the last Jedi Luke Skywalker
is in it so is right that's really what
we know there is something about this
title that makes me think this movie's
going in the direction I think will not
this movie but this new trilogy 7 8 9 I
have felt for a while now that
so nine should end with Luke Skywalker
dead Rey dead kylo Ren dead and Snoke
dead anyone in everyone who is a force
user light slide darkside Jedi evil
should all be dead no more space Wizards
no more magic we're now in an era of
technology the Magi war is done we are
now in the beginning of Final Fantasy 6
I don't know why was just the last Jedi
makes me think they're going that route
the title itself celebrates the fact
that did the last Jedi the one don't
this up because after one is none
episode 6 ended with the return of the
Jedi now we're here episode 8 the last
Jedi man that returned did not last long
and he gives us a lot to talk about
super ominous as lettering though for
sure nothing gives a little pick-me-up
PAP like red and black lettering so
anyhow I'm really pumped forward I like
the title the last Jedi I don't know I
was thinking of something a little more
ethereal you know like Shroud of the
dark side like the force awakens it's
like the last Jedi we're talking about
it person and it brings it down in scope
to a personal story which probably has
layered meanings that we will get in the
film after one really like it so Star
Wars the last Jedi is the title for Star
Wars Episode 8 what do you think about
it whenever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]